[Music]
[Applause]
Jim Jackson NBA on TNT Clippers analyst
Fox college basketball analyst always
great to talk to Jim all right as a fan
the most heartbreak that you've ever
felt in your life was when what
happened uh my son missed a shot in the
final four against Kentucky
uh to go to the championship game the
first year they went foret what year it
was with that Wisconsin team with Frank
Kaminsky and those guys that right there
was was it if and I had to do you know
it's funny after the game I was working
for the Big 10 Network and I had to
actually interview him after the
game yeah he talking about some emotions
man it was but it I mean it was a great
moment you know in regards to capturing
the moment but
you know I can deal with my
disappointment because that's something
I can control a little bit more but when
it's your child and you watch that and
then that happens it's it's something
different man okay but can you separate
yourself from being dad to being a
broadcaster doing your job to ask your
son about the shot that he missed oh no
doubt because I I covered him from um
you know his freshman year and they and
the Big 10 Network actually took me off
of his games but I would do Studio would
do the big uh 10 championships and I
would interview him but I always said
this that whether it's a personal
relationship or a child or a sibling to
me it's if you allow the game to dictate
what you talk about then you don't have
an issue now you may be able to provide
a little bit more insight on a
particular player because you have more
personal knowledge but as long as you
let the game dictate what you talk about
and not make it personal I don't really
see I never had anue with it I wonder if
the NBA has a scoring
problem that there's too much too much
yeah is it possible to have too much
scoring in the
NBA I mean you had that in the 70s you
had some high scoring you know going on
in the 70s so and I think
um I think it's the rules itself even in
the 70s it was physical but guys scored
the ball I mean that was I think that
was the difference the rules were a
little bit a lot different in regards to
the physicality but yet there were
outlier teams like the Denver Nuggets
Phoenix Suns uh back in those days uh
that would score a lot of points okay um
today you know Davis Stern late Adam
Silver late 90s you know talked about it
about Kevin Garnett talked about you
know what Steph does that they needed to
change it up a little bit more freedom
of movement and now I think it's gone we
we've gone to a point where it was not
enough freedom of movement to weigh over
the arch a little bit more to now as if
you want a defensive player a guy that
really wants to make a name for himself
it's tough to do that in the league
today because of the rules yeah nobody's
really locking somebody down it used to
be like Gary pton was the glove yeah I
mean nobody comes in and like they have
a nickname like
that well no because it's
you know then it was it wasn't as much
in regards to switching defenses because
size did matter in regards to those
switches okay when you played the pick
and rooll you got over the top you
trapped it a little bit big guy got back
um you didn't switch small to big a lot
maybe guard to guard sometimes forward
to guard a little bit but for the most
part you really did play a little bit
more one-on-one defense with an
individual and trust me I know I had to
guard Michael Jordan a lot so that
wasn't always fun but it was a challenge
you know especially against some of the
better players in the league that for
the majority of the game you would get
an opportunity to match up against them
now it's so easy when the screen comes
oh just switch it yeah just just switch
it and you don't get penalized sometimes
for it now teams will try to identify
the weakest link in the defense but then
the way the rules are too with the
switching a little bit of zone defense
you can shift over a little bit more and
kind of take that away at some point
sometimes not all the time I don't know
if you heard Jason kid talking about
Luca donic that he's already better than
Dirk and you can put him in the
atmosphere with Kobe and LeBron and
Michael talent wise talent wise scoring
what you say yeah scoring not from a
from a winning perspective now again it
took Mike you know six years seven years
whatever eight years to be able to
really start to win and win big yeah
okay we forget about that Dirk a little
bit later Dirk was a late bloomer in
regards to his body and again the G the
game was more physical he played on the
post a little bit more as his career
progressed remember Dan that's when he
started to move out a little bit more
play on the wing play on the free throw
line
extended um so that's the difference
Kobe had to go through his learning
process early okay you the only person
like LeBron and Michael when he first
came in the league he was able to go
Kobe wasn't able to go you know he had
to learn it he had to go through that
Utah series when he shot the air ball he
had to go through that Luca came right
in and was kind of anointed which from
his perspective he was talented enough
to be able to do that at 18 years old
dirk wasn't at that time when he came
into the league so I can see the
comparison is why at this stage of their
career yes I would I would agree with
that yeah I just wonder why why put that
out there that you're now you're putting
in him in I I know as the coach you want
to compliment your player yeah I think
there's enough pressure on Luca because
he's going to get to that point just
like embiid hey you know embiid's won
these MVPs you haven't won a title we
did that to the Joker hey you won MVPs
you didn't win a title now he's won a
title Giannis we did that to him Lucas
next in line two where we're going to go
okay you're getting 73 in a game but is
your team going to be playing for a
championship anytime soon well let me
ask you this Dan what how was the
question posed and why did Jason talk
about that I mean I think context is key
with that too I don't know what the
question was but yeah I don't I don't
know if Jason just offered that let's it
had to be some contextual background to
why that he gave that answer at that
time I we'll see if we can find what
that question was we're talking to Jim
Jackson NBA on TNT Clippers analyst here
but you know 70 points in a
game it's not that big a deal anymore no
it's not it's you know now you you can't
take that away from an individual
because you still got to make some
baskets you still got to get to the free
throw you still gotta do all those
little things to be able to score the
ball but if that was let say
2002 and you scored 73 I mean it would
be everywhere it would but now when you
have
73 and then you have Devin Booker
scoring 62 in the same night kind of
what happened who who was it when embiid
scored 70 and Carl Town scored 6263 yeah
it's just like yeah but and again as a
basketball player you don't want to take
away from the individual what he did but
the game allows it's like right now
you're big football fan back in the day
you don't think Joe
Montana those Troy Amman won the pass
the ball 30 times 40 times think about
their career numbers and where they
would be yeah so that's why when I get
into comparing numbers and and stats is
skewed because Larry Bird shot one or
two three-pointers a game compared to
Steph and that's not taking anything
away from Steph but you got to put in
context he's taking 8 nine 10 a game so
his numbers are going to be extremely
high in regards to makes and attempts so
that's why it's a little bit tougher you
know what I mean yeah who is the most
unguardable player in the NBA right
now the most unguardable embiid okay and
I say embiid From jokic's perspective he
jic and MB from from a different
perspective jic doesn't hunt shots he
just beat
you and I think Michael Malone and the
Nuggets do an outstanding job of mve
moving him around the board like a chest
piece so you just can't say okay we're
going to take him away from the right
block or left block or put him at the
elbow and he's everywhere he'll bring it
up the court you know and then make a
play so stopping him from doing what
being very effective not just scoring
see sometimes embiid struggles when we
get into the playoffs scoring wise they
put a smaller guy on them why because
now when you come to help it's a big
that comes to help so that double team
is different with yic I don't care what
you do he can beat you by having the
triple double and only have 18 points
that to me is unguardable because you
can't take away everything that makes he
and his team so effective okay but the
most Unstoppable
score that this guy could put up 81
points in a
game oh MB you can't stop him you can
you cannot stop MB if he wants to get to
a spot if he wants to post you up he's
going to get to the free throw you can't
it's it's no physical matchup in the
league that can take away if he's really
determine if he wants to put the ball in
the hoop nobody because he unlike
Giannis he can step out and knock down
to three shooting like 37% from
three-point line he shoots plus 80% from
the free throw line well I mean what are
you gonna take away if he's really
determined and the team is really
determined to get him the ball what you
going to
do I mean that's you can't stop it
LeBron had an interesting comment after
last night's loss and uh you think I'll
let you I'll let you I'll let you hear
it what is he saying in this passive
aggressive
message on any given Night Beat any team
in the
NBA and then On Any Given night we get
our ass kicked by any team in the
NBA that's just a what's our record one
one game under 500 that's what we've
seen under one game under 500 yeah
2425 that's where we are okay who is he
sending that message to
Jim um I like the point he said what's
our record he already knew it was it was
a rhetorical question then he gave him
the answer right after the 242 he
already knew the answer you know what I
mean it's like it's it's and this is
what I caution always though digging
into a mind of a player and what they
actually think because it's so diff
especially
that caliber of player on everything
that he's been through and I caution
people a lot of times because you think
they mean one thing and they're saying
something else now LeBron is great at
giving subliminal messages okay across
the board we know that throughout the
course of his career so there's a
history there and sometimes you're
sitting back okay what does he what is
he really trying to say yeah without
saying it you know Kobe would just say
it he'll tell you this is this is what
I'm saying Mike was like that in some
ways Charles was like that Charles would
tell you in a heartbeat you remember
that that's why he's so so good on TNT
and TV LeBron is a little bit different
I don't know if he was saying it from
now it is truth in that on like I you
know they beat us with the Clippers
twice okay you can beat some of the best
teams like they did Golden State that
double overtime was fantastic but then
you come back and lose but I think that
goes to the inconsistency of the team in
the roster too on where they're at at
this particular place of the Season he's
probably frustrated about it too do you
think he ends his career with the
Lakers well I thought he would in his
career in Cleveland I mean what do I
know you know from that perspective
because of what he you know value the
most in regards to Cleveland and again
that's why it's hard for me because at
that Elite level Dan we we don't see
that a lot mean I don't care if it's
football baseball hockey basketball
whatever it is track and field uh
Olympic sports they think different man
it's a different
mindset and for him to be able to
perform the way he's performing at this
age and leaving a
legacy would I be
surprised no but there's only I think as
he gets deeper into closer to 40 you got
a limited amount of teams that really
would take on LeBron James because of
the gravity that he brings and now he's
an older player that was when he was 33
different story the market is not going
to be the same for 40y old LeBron James
as it is for a 33 it's like Bill bich
factoring in his age and what he would
want and it scares it scares away teams
I believe and LeBron probably scared too
were you so were you did you think the
market for bill bich was robust when
that happened with New England or did
you say to
yourself you really don't have a lot of
option what what did you think I didn't
think that he would only have one
interview but I think he focused on the
Falcons and that's where he knew that he
had a team that had underachieved and he
he could make them better quicker I
didn't think the other teams I thought
Washington might interview him uh just
because he grew up in the proximity you
know apis Maryland uh that that might be
it but you know it's like Mike Vel Mike
Vel is probably not going to get a job
and he's a really good coach Pete
Carroll is not going to get a job this
year it's just y you know we're we're
seeing I mean this all happened and you
throw in Nick sabbin I could just it was
such a crazy week or two where these
coaches were getting fired not hired or
retiring and they may not get hired any
anytime soon well I mean with Bill too
you think about
it Cleveland fired not successful but
you got to New England you had a great
owner you drafted great Tom Brady ended
up being one of the greatest
quarterbacks maybe the greatest
quarterback ever played a game so that
worked perfectly for that time period
and you know as you age out in sports or
that's age out in business the reason
why they put retirement in for a certain
at a certain period of time your market
value is not the same and it's
unfortunate but did Bill want more
control too from the front office
perspective maybe Atlanta was a team he
looked at and said not only could I have
control from a coaching perspective but
in the front office also have that
control and a lot of teams I know
weren't willing just talking to a lot of
football guys I know weren't willing to
give that up oh there's no question
there's no question that he would want
to go in and be Bill bich and run run
the
organization and you know I think that's
where these other you know franchises
probably didn't want to they weren't
entertaining that either so I don't know
I think he takes one year off does TV
and then maybe you get you Philadelphia
you know they fire their head coach Nick
serani if they don't meet you go to the
conference title game if the Cowboys
don't go to the conference title game
Mike McCarthy's last year I could see
that before I let you go so here was the
question how much of that performance by
Luca was a reaction to the criticism he
got after the Suns game the thing with
the fan or was it just one of those
crazy wild nights so I would say I would
say combination because Luke LCA is
sensitive from from the perspective of
he
listen we got rabbit ears you hear and
see everything today you can't you in
today's world with social media and
everything you can't get away with don't
don't say that you don't listen you
don't I don't know it's impossible it is
whether that's somebody telling you that
or you pop open a your exfeed or
Instagram whatever it may be you're
going to hear it
local what whatever it is so whether
that the fuel to the fire was the fact
that now it's a lot easier for players
to get fans ejected back when we were
playing we had hecklers all the time
remember Robert uh what was Rob the
attorney's name in DC oh what
waser fer fer oh he would sit right
behind the Ben it was now he wasn't
saying anything racial but he was
classic and you couldn't get rid of him
until something happened it was one in
Cleveland I think it was one in Detroit
it was UN I mean unreal I mean
unbelievable okay but how personal are
they getting with you no I mean one time
I mean Quinn Buckner drawn up a play and
he's in the back he said Emy Jackson
Amore Mashburn AC kid I don't know why
you playing none of y'all got any
I
mean stuff like that but and he will
hold up a chalk board behind don't
listen to him he doesn't know what he's
talking about you know just at some
point you look forward to actually
seeing and listening to what he's going
to say but you know I think Luca he's at
that point of his career too
where the Mavericks have been in between
they got to Western Conference Finals
okay can you get over over the top yeah
and it seems like we don't talk about
Dallas but because of the roster
construction especially in the Western
Conference it makes it more difficult to
put him in that conversation because he
hasn't won yet but he's been to the
Western Conference
fine it's great to talk to you us always
always man listen can you send me some
of that that concoction you want some
moonshine that peppermint bark you don't
get that in Zanesville bro that don't
you don't they don't grow there I'm uh
I'm I'm maybe salted carel give you some
of
that no was that your nickname was that
your nickname at Ohio State salted
caramel not Sal the caramel close though
it was listen but you make sure I can
pair with a nice cigar you gotta make
sure I can pair with a nice cigar if I
could do that moonshine it is well maybe
I'll send it to Jordan too because he
loves his cigars as well did you ever
have a cigar with Jordan think I didn't
oh man that that's that's how I got into
cigars oh okay because Mike because Ron
Harper during their second three repat I
used to go to Chicago with him and they
would do you know Mike used to smoke on
the way to the
game and it and his
ferari which
one yeah I remember seeing Mike pull up
you know at the Chicago stadium in his
car and uh and he would get out and he
would have a cigar going he'd be
Su suit on having a cigar um must be
nice bro yeah yeah living the life uh
thank you buddy good to talk to you
again always man that's Jim Jackson MBA
on TNT Clippers analyst and fox college
basketball analyst